the boy's second season has come to a
violent and twisty close and in between
decapitations you may have caught a few
small but important details over the
last few episodes leading up to the
finale
here are a few of those details in case
you missed them no one will ever accuse
homeland or being even remotely stable
but that doesn't mean he can't unravel
even more
this season has been particularly
stressful for the sevens leader as he
tries to deal with issues surrounding a
new team member
as well as the troubles that come with
being a superhero dad so it shouldn't be
surprising that he might snap it's been
established that homelander has the soup
doppelganger portraying the woman he
killed madeleine stillwell for some cozy
cuddling
this shapeshifter takes things in a
different direction when homelander
utters one troubling phrase
i don't need anyone
but myself
that leads into a rather awkward
conversation that doesn't end well
the situation resembles a scene in issue
49 of the comic in which homelander
stands in front of a mirror and talks to
himself
here someone speaks back but there's a
bit of a twist which we won't spoil here
but in both cases it looks as if we get
to see homelander breaking down after
being confronted by himself
showing the cracks in his psyche a bit
more clearly everyone has issues with
her family but saying that about the
relationship between billy butcher and
his father may be putting it too lightly
and he's done everything he can to keep
his distance eventually billy is
suckered into coming to see his mother
who lies and says that his father has
died this is enough to get him there but
only to see that his dad is still alive
leading to a fight about his dead
brother lenny butcher's father tries to
argue that the abusive patriarch's
actions made him the strong man he is
today
near the end of episode 7 butcher meets
up with his mother one more time
who confirms that his father does not
have long to live
tell me what happens
it isn't just a funny remark or an empty
promise his father's abuse bothers young
william so much that he grabs a kitchen
knife with the intent to kill his old
man but lenny stops him
huey not only plays the same role that
lenny did as butcher's conscience but
it's even mentioned that the two look
the same
drawing more of a parallel in the
butcher baker candlestick maker
miniseries that explains butcher's past
he's looking down at the corpse of his
father
going over his backstory and when he's
done he does just what he promised
the season 2 finale has a few instances
that parallel with comics especially in
regards to setting up the next season
stormfront getting beaten down and
losing an eye is just one instance but
the big one has to be in the climax to
the whole season
there's a lot of fighting going on in
those important few minutes and it looks
like things are going to turn out even
worse
but the ticking time bomb viewers we're
waiting for all season finally goes off
with a little push
and there are some casualties not only
is the neo-nazi storm front left as a
shell of her former self but becca is
also caught in ryan's blast
in the comics becca's death is a little
more brutal she's unknowingly pregnant
and the baby growing inside of her
develops powers and exits the womb
violently killing rebecca and shooting
off its heat vision while flying around
the room
this leaves butcher stunned for a moment
but he ends up beating the killer baby
to death with a lamp
this kind of happens in the show too
until we learn that becca survived a
difficult birth
all that history explains why some
viewers got pretty worried after seeing
butcher pick up a crowbar in the episode
thankfully things played out a little
bit differently here but the event was
obviously emotional
and the trauma of the moment will linger
with butcher for quite some time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you